after over three decades of friendship
and love John Travolta gets vulnerable
over the death of Kirsty alley
[Music]
Harry World Series kind of thing among
her many roles Kersey alley is fondly
remembered for her work in the Look
Who's Talking Trilogy released in 1989
Look Who's Talking follows single mother
Molly Jensen played by Ali who struggles
to take care of her newborn baby whose
thoughts are Illustrated through voice
over narration by Bruce Willis along the
way a relationship grows between Molly
and cab driver James played by John
Travolta with the two eventually falling
in love the film's surprising financial
success led to two sequels being
produced and these saw the family grow
by adding one daughter and two dogs
despite the movies themselves never
quite becoming critical Darlings what
remains undeniable was the chemistry
shared by Ali and Travolta who stuck
through all three entries even when
these movies are at their worst the
fictional couple was always a bright
spot and provided an endless array of
fun relatable and heartwarming moments
sadly if the long rumored reboot the
franchise ever comes to fruition one of
its most important names won't get to
see or star in it on December 5th 2022
Kirsty alley died of cancer shortly
after being diagnosed with colon cancer
the actress will not only be missed by
the fans whose memories she helped shape
with her memorable performances and
cheers Star Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan and
David's mother but also by those who
worked with her fans of the Look Who's
Talking films may be wondering just how
Travolta is taking the tragic news and
if the two are close to begin with
unsurprisingly their friendship was very
strong to the point that they were
almost more than friends the news of
Kirstie Alley's death came as a surprise
to everyone even those in the
entertainment World once the news began
making the rounds celebrities May
disappoint to pay tribute to her in some
formal fashion unsurprisingly John
travolsa did the exact same after
learning of Ali's death Travolta was
understandably heartbroken to say the
least the Bob fiction star quickly took
to social media to share a few words
about his a co-star and expressed his
love for her in a heartfelt December 5th
Instagram post he wrote Kirsty was one
of the most special relationships I've
ever had I love you Kirsty I know we
will see each other again alongside the
short yet emotional caption Travolta
shared a photo of Ali along with another
from back in the day that features both
of them with ear to ear Smiles on their
faces the comments section is full of
kind messages honoring Ali's memory
supporting Travolta during this
difficult time and more Kirsty alley and
John Travolta's radiant chemistry in the
Look Who's Talking Trilogy was unlimited
to the 90s rom-com franchise 30 years
after the film was released Ali would
appear at the premiere of Travolta's
2019 film The Fanatic at the Egyptian
Theater red carpet event in Hollywood
Travolta made it clear just how much he
adores Ali as a human being he told us
weekly she's my soul mate it's been 30
years since look who's talking I would
do anything with Kirsty so let's see
what happens as it turns out Travolta
isn't the only one who sends an instant
connection between him and Ali her
feelings for Travolta run even deeper as
she would reveal on a 2018 episode of
Celebrity Big Brother UK I I almost ran
off and married John I did love him I
still love him if I hadn't been married
I would have I would have gone and
married she knows that working with him
for such an extended period of time led
to her falling in love with him saying
it's very easy to fall in love with your
leading man for a year you're around
this person it's just hard I think while
we'll never get a dream John Travolta
and Kirsty alley reunion their work and
look who's talking will live on as a
testament to their love for one another
foreign
[Music]